getting rich quick
[Music]
it's a tempting idea isn't it here's my
story i'm on holiday with some good
friends i've got a little bit of money
saved up and i lose the majority of it
on that holiday
reckless spending breaking a phone is a
whole other story but
i'm home with pennies in my bank account
and around this time i was losing my
passion for acting something i'd been
doing since i was a kid and when you
aspire to be an actor you kind of just
assume that you're gonna be broke until
you make it but now
i actually needed money i didn't have
that mental safety net anymore
so i go on the internet and i start
searching for things like how to make
money
online i begin encountering these gurus
you know the tai lopez's the grant
cardones people who
at any other point in time i would have
considered sleazy
at best but i fell into this rabbit hole
of desperation
these concepts like passive income or
being your own boss were presented to me
on a silver spoon and i ate it all up
i began to hate the idea of a nine to
five it was like admitting failure in
life
these gurus sold me on a dream dream of
getting rich quick
dangling it in front of me like a carrot
on a stick except it was an online
course
teaching me how to do it i didn't know
it then but i was diving into the realm
of get rich quick schemes and do you
want to know the twist
i got off lightly i only got a taste of
what the world of get rich quick schemes
is like
they're very slightly very sneaky kind
of like snake anyone can fall down this
rabbit hole they'll hit all the major
you know pain points in people's lives
catch somebody at the right time
under the right context no matter how
educated smart or self-aware you are
you can fall for a get-rich-quick scheme
i'm pretty sure that's a pyramid and the
guy pitching would be like no it's a
triangle
presented with this opportunity that
might get you out of the rubble and it's
really
manipulative
i wanted to find out why snake
oil salesman it's a phrase that's been
around for a while usually referring to
someone who's dishonest a con artist
a trader of fake medicines a grifter but
have you ever wondered
where the term came from there was this
man named clark stanley who traveled
around america
selling rattlesnake oil through what are
known as medicine shows
large crowds would gather as stanley
claimed his snake oil based on chinese
water snake oil could cure
all sorts of ailments known to man only
this wasn't true
at all and when stanley's rattlesnake
oil was examined in 1916 it was found to
have
no snake oil in it at all it was
worthless from then on the phrase
snake oil salesman has been around in
pop culture depicted as a salesman that
would go from town to town peddling
their cures to the vulnerable
these people have existed all throughout
time with a different pitch
or version of the same scheme but it's
the methods the tools of influence that
remain
constant i believe i was roped into the
modern
internet version of snake oil salesman
the online guru that would set
ridiculously high expectations around
their products
despite the product largely not being
able to fulfill on those expectations
the scam isn't an online course but the
salesman's marketing around it and here
i am again
wondering why i or anyone for that
matter
falls for something like this so i
decided to take a look at some of the
snake oil salesmen of the not so distant
past
and i came across infomercials the 80s
answer to medicine shows
the dream of financial success thanks to
gary cochran i've made over four
thousand dollars
checks money orders and major credit
cards are accepted let gary cochran show
you how to get a second paycheck
hawaiian style
these are infomercials and they became
huge in the 1980s and 90s
they're essentially program length
commercials that can last anywhere from
28 minutes to 60 minutes in length
usually airing outside of prime time
hours we're talking 1am to 6am a lot of
infomercials promoted
legitimate products sometimes with a
celebrity backing it but they also
attracted a ton of
questionable products individuals and
marketing tactics
throughout the program watchers would be
presented with a toll-free number to
call
to place their order for the advertised
product for a snake oil salesman
this was the new medicine show
motivational and personal development
products ran
rampant and along with it came get rich
quick infomercials
this man was called don le pre a
self-proclaimed
king of infomercials i found tiny
classified ads and i place those ads
in around a thousand other newspapers
around the country
that's how i generated over 50 000
a week and guess what he promised that
you could too i don't care who you are i
don't care where you live i don't care
how much money you have
anyone with a lick of sense can do this
i got a system
this system just how easy it is easily
just too
easy to be real and here's where we
notice the patterns begin to emerge
la pre promises four essential things
that you can get rich
that it can happen quickly and that
anyone can do it and
he has a system that can help you don le
pre was selling three programs each
supposedly teaching people how to run
tiny classified ads in newspapers and
make a profit from
it but the truth is this most people
buying these programs
wouldn't have been able to generate the
sort of money that capri was promising
because making a profit from classified
ads was not as easy as laprie was making
them out to be
and consider the obvious here lapree was
making money from selling the programs
on the infomercials
not through tiny classified ads but
remember the patterns
because get rich quick schemes promise
the same things over
and over again a step-by-step system and
then i finally developed a system
pretty easy to do if you just follow my
system step
by step it's not that you can't make
money through real estate or classified
ads
it's that the way in which these
programs are marketed
are completely polar opposite to the
realities of what they're trying to sell
snake oil had its benefits but it was by
no means a miracle cure
when i look back at the internet gurus
that i knew of i
see the exact same patterns emerging the
promise of a business model like drop
shipping but packaged and marketed in
such a way that will leave someone
thinking that it's an easy gig
how would you like to make an extra one
thousand dollars a month for doing
absolutely nothing even for the most
average of people
you then apply standard marketing
techniques to further influence your
audience
social proof is one example which is
created by using ordinary citizens or
figures of authority as testimonials for
how great the program is
but you don't have to take just my word
for it without gary's course
we would be bankrupt you know without a
doubt it worked absolutely everybody
would be successful that uses gary's
course they often included a backstory
on how they were once poor and became
rich
making sure that it relates as much as
possible to their target audience let me
tell you my situation
i needed more cash my bills exceeded my
income
am i the only one with that problem i
doubt it in my case
i was desperate for money i wanted to
make my parents proud i felt like
working at nine to five meant i was a
failure my vulnerability is what wrote
me
into this world and all the while i was
sat there thinking that i was the clever
one that i had taken the red pill whilst
others around me couldn't see what i saw
in the gurus that i followed now these
schemes were centered around the idea of
teaching someone how to get rich quick
but unfortunately
infomercials and the gurus i encountered
are only the tip
of the iceberg that are get rich quick
schemes because trust me
things get a lot more darker from here
before we continue though a quick
message from the sponsors of today's
video
nordvpn if you're browsing the internet
using your phone or your computer which
chances are you're doing it right now
your internet service provider has
access to
all of that data they can see exactly
what you are up to and that is where
nordvpn comes in because not only do
they hide your internet traffic
from your service provider but they also
let you change
the country that you're accessing the
internet from so for example
if you've ever encountered a website
that was blocked or there's a show on
netflix that is not available in your
country you can quickly
open up nordvpn on any device that you
have select the country that you want to
connect to and then
access that website or that show for
example if you're in the us
and you want to watch a louis theroux
documentary i know that you can't
because it's not available in the us
but what you can do is go on to nordvpn
on that device
select the uk as the country that you're
in go back to netflix and there you go
you're basically able to watch all the
louis through documentaries on there
as well as any other show that is
exclusively on the uk netflix
so right now nordvpn are offering a huge
discount on their two-year plan as well
as a bonus gift of four additional free
months
if you click the link in the description
below or you go to nordvpn.com
forward slash james janney it's also
risk free so you get a 30 day
money back guarantee if you're not happy
with it these guys are genuinely
a sponsor that i'm happy to promote i
use them every single day they're
extremely affordable again
they are offering a huge discount as
well on their two year plan
and an additional gift of four free
additional months if you click the link
in the description below or you go to
nordvpn.com forward slash james jenny
that being said let's jump right back
into the video
in the years of 2012 to 2014 an energy
drink began to circulate
across college campuses in the us on the
surface
verve was marketed as a healthy
alternative to energy drinks but this
drink was nothing more than a front
for something much darker verve was
created by the company known as
vemma a multi-level marketing company
that used distributors
to sell their products and as a
distributor you could get a cut from
selling vemma's products
even better as a distributor you could
recruit other distributors and earn a
commission from anything the
distributors below you made blink twice
and you'll miss what's going on here see
vemma wasn't focused on the selling of
their products
they were more interested in recruiting
more distributors
across these college campuses students
were being messaged by
friends about a business opportunity
which eventually led them into a room
where they were pitched this opportunity
when you watch these pictures you
realize that this
isn't about selling an energy drink this
is selling
a dream you can be 16 to make as much
money as you want you can be 85 make as
much money as you want if you're sitting
here tonight you know 14
18 23 this really is the greatest
opportunity of your life
vemma targeted high schools and
universities places where people were
young
naive trying to figure out what they
wanted to do with their lives during a
time in which their future was uncertain
i'm 19 years old and i'm kind of just
like really looking for a direction
that was a hook for me it was getting my
parents out of poverty and setting
myself up for the future financially so
the thing that they would pitch to
is the reason that they would target
college kids is that i quote it's a
replenishing market
vemma was a pyramid scheme which is
another form of a get-rich-quick scheme
distributors were told that the real way
to make money in the company
was by recruiting others and new
recruits would be told to do the same
thing
now if one person recruited five people
and those five people each recruited
five more and so on and so forth
you can only keep this going for 14
levels before you run out of the
population of the entire world
in this type of scheme only those who
get in right at the start make money
whilst the majority
lose their money and it's very likely
that by the time you've heard about the
scheme
you're already too late almost 90
percent of the recruits in vemma were
making less than four thousand dollars a
year and that's not including the money
that they had to spend on buying the
actual product
in truth the majority of vemma's young
recruits were losing money
vemma was a scam that operated in a
cult-like
fashion to keep the recruits inside of
the company some kids had even
dropped out of college or ostracized
themselves from friends and families and
changed their entire social media
presence
to promote this company the cult
component of it
i think really drives people to keep
doing it you're this circle of people
that are doing what you're doing and
it's kind of like an echo chamber
of the same stuff being said over and
over again but vemma
is one of countless mlm companies that
are still around today but they all seem
to follow a similar pattern
relying on recruitment over-promising
the results that one could get from the
opportunity
and they rely on another trait building
a sense of community around the scheme
if all your friends are part of the same
scheme believing in the same things as
you do then it becomes harder to escape
that echo chamber in fact there are
social repercussions for not remaining
in the scheme
your world becomes the scheme in fact
for those outside of the scheme
sometimes a fear of missing out is
enough to pull you in
a huge reason that i fell under the
influence of
get rich quick gurus is that i had
completely entrenched myself
in that community i read the literature
they wanted me to read their content
consumed my feed and most
important was my lack of willingness to
critically assess what i was being sold
on until i started noticing these
patterns continuing to emerge
the patterns in the pitch the marketing
and actual results i and others around
me were getting and when i found out
what i'd been falling into i felt a lot
of anger
and shame
[Music]
here's how it goes to keep you inside of
the scheme two critical elements will be
at play
the first is blaming yourself to make
you feel as though this must be your
fault despite the schemes exaggerated
promises
no matter how hard you work is they tell
you they're like you're doing something
wrong there's something you're not doing
right as [ __ ] with your head because
you start to lose your self-confidence
and you're sitting there like what could
i possibly be doing wrong vemma would
often promote the pseudo-scientific
belief of the law of attraction
one that made them think that if they
weren't successful they only had
themselves
to blame ignoring the fact that they are
in a scheme that is designed to fail
the second although not always present
is that the scheme will create a
community around it everybody say yes
coach
yes coach do it again
do it again specifically a community
that is told to not listen to outside
criticism
to distance themselves from those who
are not inside of the scheme as well
we all belong in various communities
there's nothing wrong with that but when
that community specifically
aims to cut you off from any outside
opinions or criticisms
then it's a massive red flag one aspect
that makes cults
so effective in their brainwashing is
doing exactly that they have an ability
to control the information that the
members are receiving
and all the information had to come from
them outside opinion would be
immediately discredited as haters or
dream stealers but let's pause for a
second
because there's a slight problem with
this deconstruction
and the problem is that many of these
elements exist in legitimate products
businesses brands and influencers
sometimes it's
very easy to spot a get rich quick scam
get rich quick
infomercials are almost too easy to
notice once you understand the rhetoric
and the promises that these schemes
typically make but other times it's
harder to distinguish
not every person selling a course is
promoting a get-rich-quick scheme
my system for distinguishing the good
from the bad is by first
looking at the expectations that are
presented in the packaging do these
expectations seem
realistic who is the person and company
behind it does a google search of that
individual or company result in
incriminating information
poor reviews or red flags does the
marketing use
social proof scarcity or any other
tactic in a disingenuous way
for example is the live webinar that
they are promoting
actually pre-recorded are they claiming
to have a limited time offer
when in fact that offer has never been
changed but when that timer hits zero
everything i've talked about here today
comes off the table recognizing the
common marketing techniques being used
takes you out of an easily influenced
state and brings awareness to the fact
that you're being sold to but ultimately
there is one final piece in all of this
the final lesson i had to learn that
took me out of this world of get rich
quick schemes a lesson
on responsibility getting rich quick is
technically
possible some win the lottery others
might start a company which sells for a
fortune
a few years later winning the lottery is
based on luck
but the latter that is far from easy if
you're being promised a product or
service that claims to make it easy
that's the biggest red flag you need
going through all of these schemes
understanding how this stuff has been
around for centuries
how everyone from every generation has
fallen for it it makes you realize
our brains are filled with many biases
things that at any point can trip you up
if you're not careful
seeing the patterns in get rich quick
schemes was a first step in
stopping myself from going any further
but there was one last thing for me to
do
i had to stop buying the dream and start
doing something anything that didn't
involve me
sitting around fantasizing about passive
income or a laptop lifestyle or the idea
of wealth and especially
the idea that i could get rich easily
because doing that
ultimately made me susceptible to being
influenced in the way that i was
hello my friends and thank you for
watching the good ending to my story
is it eventually led me to you you know
i learned how to edit videos i kind of
combined some skills i learned when i
was doing acting and i brought something
to youtube that i felt might be
different so i definitely owe it to all
of you that continue to stick around and
watch my content if you want to see more
hit the subscribe button it's totally
free but i promise to bless
your feed with only good content i've
also got a patreon where i do
q and a's i do video editing tutorials
where i break down some of the effects
that you might see in the videos the
link for that is in the description
below that is probably one of the best
ways that you can support the channel if
you're so kind as to do so without all
being said as always my friends i look
forward to seeing you in the next
video hand to head salute to many days
is yet to come
too many times has come to
pass